[Music]
the current approach today is
essentially we've entered into a culture
of frenetic ISM it's a big think word
and that means we're really busy but I
believe we've created the busyness on
ourselves ultimately we've become
distracted by school the next thing that
pops into our head or the next thing
that pops onto our device or the next
thing that pops into our laptop we're
addressing it and for some reason we
think it's a good idea to attend to
every notification every want of an
employee every need of a boss and so we
are loading ourselves up with more to do
we are ultimately working on the next
thing while we're doing the current
thing at the same time we think that
multitasking is a badge of honor we
think that do more with less is the
corporate mantra that's going to take us
to gold metal plates and it's
frightening and what we need to do is to
take a step back and say how did we get
here
is it good and what's in store for the
future right now I mean ultimately are
our team members our bosses are leaders
right they're walking around like
zombies and it's not good
we go from one meeting to another we're
in a peripatetic state right we're just
Altima going from the eight o'clock to
the nine o'clock to the ten o'clock the
11 o'clock we used to go out for lunch
and pause but now we go get lunch we
bring it to our desk and we stare at
another device trying to catch up with
everything that we haven't done between
eight and twelve and then we go the next
meeting at 1:00 and we end up at 5:00
and then you know we maybe pick up the
kids or we got to go to soccer practice
instead of looking at the soccer
practice and the kids at that soccer
practice we're looking at our device
because there's eight more texts and 15
more emails that have come in and now
it's M o'clock you've got to make dinner
and when seven o'clock your dinner like
well I don't actually know how to make
dinner anymore so you order and then
while you're ordering you're attending
to all your social streams you're saying
oh well I forgot how much I like
dopamine so I like those red things on
my phone and my laptop that say hey I've
got eight likes on Instagram and twenty
four legs on Facebook maybe I'll post
more and then all of a sudden sixteen
more emails come in and you've got 14
more tasks to do because now you're at 9
o'clock
Wow I don't know maybe I should just
watch something and so you binge
watching
Netflix for the 15th time and that is 12
o'clock you do the same thing over again
so for some reason we think this is a
good thing we think that you know being
constantly busy without having to pause
the meandering of thought the marination
in the moment we think that you know we
just got to be constantly on and that's
a good thing
but it's not what we're doing is
creating balls of cortisol that means
that we've got cortisol emitting from
every orifice in our body if we see that
the APA is telling us that our levels of
stress have increased since 1982 about a
third of us are suffering from chronic
stress in the workplace we see other
studies that suggest that half of us
bring that state of stress at home
creating personal stress in our personal
lives so how is this good when we're
walking around like with balls of
cortisol and you know in from every
orifice it emitting I don't see where
this ends well for us in society one of
the things that we ought to be thinking
about like I suppose any good book does
is think of things in a two-by-two
matrix right that simplifies everything
in our lives and so if we we do that
then we're fine really
but in my case I'm suggesting that
there's there's a Y in an x axis and
we're only on the x axis the x axis is
action so we seem to be stuck in the
bottom right-hand quadrant if you're
kind of following a two-by-two matrix so
we're down here and that's where action
is and we just sort of live in that
state there's more than 50% of us that
are ultimately just doing all the time
we're addicted to the doing but the word
I think I want to reintroduce to society
is reflection when we reflect so back
here now in the Y X is when we reflect
we are ultimately common during our time
right what we're doing is we're looking
at our calendar and saying is there any
white space what we're doing is we're
saying okay when way take that elevator
ride up to the 43rd floor in you know a
hotel in New York and Manhattan am I not
looking at a device and I possibly
actually saying hello to someone in an
elevator reflecting right to me
reflecting is also about networking
meeting people going for a walk right
without looking at your device
reflecting on what it is that maybe
allows you to be who you are who you
want to be what's your purpose where we
really need to get to is up here on the
top right and that is the balance of
reflection with action when we do that
I'm not suggesting that we don't take
action obviously we need to we need to
get things done right we've got projects
we've got tasks etc but if we do insert
more reflection time into our day that
action becomes that much more prosperous
and profitable and positive but when we
don't we just sit there doing all the
time then what ultimately ends up is
less innovation probably more
absenteeism less productivity ironically
and we end up being more stressed
you